for our daily cancellation we begin with
a recent article in the Washington Post
discussing as the headline announces
quote how psychedelic therapy might help
with climate change anxiety now the
piece is written by a mental health
professional named Emily Willow who
starts by describing a recent session
with an Eco anxious client she writes as
our weekly therapy session Drew to a
close my patient a young woman in her
early 20s approaching college graduation
said that she had been feeling a lack of
motivation but that it felt different
from her usual depressive symptoms a
worrisome Climate Change Report had Rec
recently been published and she felt
Paralyzed by uncertainty of what the
world is going to look like she asked
quote how can I decide where I want to
go will it even be safe to live in
California when I'm older many of us are
feeling a sense of powerlessness and
despair over climate change and its
harmful effects as a psychiatrist I've
noticed a growing Trend among patients
in my private practice suffering from
what mental health professionals are
calling Eco anxiety and climate
grief yes climate grief it's called
apparently the article then goes on to
claim that tripping on hallucinogens
will somehow make you less delusionally
terrified of an ecological apocalypse
because of course if you're having
trouble being reasonable and keeping
things in
perspective the best thing to do is take
LSD now that's what they always
recommend for people to help them stay
calm and collected it's why airline
pilots are encouraged to drop acid 20
minutes before takeoff I think I read
that once in the FAA handbook anyway I'm
not interested in spending any time on
the idea that hallucinatory drugs will
help you be less anxious about
unreasonable things that's the kind of
idea that you would have to already be
on drugs to believe in the first place
so it's a moot point instead I want to
talk about this this this underlying uh
concept of climate anxiety which has
been getting a lot of press lately it's
an epidemic On The Rise we're told
recently PBS did an explainer on the
topic watch recently I've been spending
a lot of time reading about climate
change and it's got me feeling
anxious a little
tense a bit fck frustrated and I'm
definitely worried about the
[Music]
future and it looks like I'm not alone
people on social media are sharing their
anxious feelings and fears about climate
change so much so there's a name for
this it's called Eco anxiety or climate
anxiety okay so this isn't isolated and
it's much larger than I thought so
before we go forward let's practice some
mindfulness come on y'all let's take a
deep breath come on deep yog breath fill
up those lungs and
another I do have good news in response
to the growing trend of Eco anxiety
clinicians and psychologists are
ushering in new techniques to help their
clients deal with this issue we going to
make it through yall one more
breath the science of ecotherapy or
climate aware therapy is evolving and
there's plenty to learn now I just want
to pause here to give us a moment to
reflect on the phrase the science of
climate aware therapy which is like
saying the science of leprechaun
research now it's already a massive
stretch to claim that any form of mental
therapy is scientific but the claim
becomes even more dubious as you begin
adding sub genres like gender affirming
therapy climate aware therapy and so on
so this is already a load of nonsense
but uh let's keep watching Eco anxiety
is a relatively new term Eco anxiety has
been defined by the American psycholog
iCal Association as The Chronic fear of
environmental Doom that's Brit Ray she's
an expert at the intersection of climate
change and mental health Brit what are
some ways someone might experience
climate anxiety it can become so intense
that it's debilitating it can impair
people's functioning and then it really
does need clinical intervention or
support but it can also trap us in a pit
of fear and hopelessness if we aren't
careful and get us carried away and kind
of a despairing narrative about the
future being written off even though
someone might be dealing with these
symptoms it might be hard for a
therapist to pinpoint the best course of
action because Eco anxiety is not in the
dsm5 the manual that health
professionals Ed to diagnose mental
health
disorders well don't worry about that uh
because that will change climate anxiety
is another way for psychiatrists and
pharmaceutical companies to make money
another another profitable mental health
related grift and so it will surely be
legitimized in the next edition of the
DSM that is after all the dsm's primary
function these days but what can be done
about climate anxiety mean that's really
the question what can we do about all
this how can it be
treated um well let's find
out the key here to unlocking strategies
to deal with your own climate anxiety
might have less to do with your
individual effort to deter climate
change such as lowering your own
greenhouse gas emissions and more to do
with building a climate crisis plan
there was a recent article in the
leading scientific journal Nature that
said an important thing that individuals
can do to address their climate anxiety
is really focus on small aspects that
they can control a lot of anxiety is
provoked by the unknown and feeling like
you can't control a situation here's
what a climate action plan might look
like if you're in a flood zone consider
using personal storage bins that are
watertight or moving personal items to a
higher level on the shelf for more info
on finding out if you live in a flood
zone check out the description below
those concerned about drought might want
to learn more about Urban gardening or
drought resistant forms of Agriculture
that you can do at home now above all
find yourself a community that is
preparing to deal with the next
catastrophic event because global
warming is happening take action and
join in on the
effort there you go if you're scared
about a global catastrophe wiping out
all of mankind uh one way to cope is to
put your belongings in plastic storage
bins or start gardening maybe take the
LSD before you go gardening just to make
it more interesting now it's worth
considering just how limp and
superficial this advice is and how
inappropriate the whole tone of that
video was if you actually buy the claim
that the world is coming to an end
because of climate change which the
people who made the video supposedly do
so in one breath they tell us that the
end of the world is at hand and the next
in the next breath they record a smiley
cheerful video assuring us that plastic
storage bins will help us through it so
there seems to be a a disconnect here
and this is the kind of Disconnect
that's um very common among climate
alarmist it's why part of me has a hard
time believing that anyone in the world
is actually this stressed out about
climate change I mean I've never met
anybody like this I've
never encountered in the wild a person
who was actually racked with grief and
fear because of the environment I've
never had this conversation ever with
anyone where they bring up you know I'm
really troubled right now because of the
um because of the climate it's never
I've never had that now granted if
anyone did have that worry they probably
wouldn't share it with me but um still
I've never encountered that and and just
for me personally it's a form of anxiety
that I just can't relate to in the
slightest I I I have I you know I can't
wrap my head around it I have anxiety
about a lot of things but I've never
spent even 1 second of my life worrying
about the climate well who doesn't like
to have their windshields clean Haze and
film can easily build up on both sides
of your car windshield causing dangerous
glare my new friends at windshield wow
are the fastest and least hassle way to
get a super clean streak free and safe
windshield the windshield wow is an
Innovative windshield cleaning device
that uses two magnetic cleaning paddles
one on the outside and one on the on the
inside of your car to clean both sides
of your windshield all from the outside
all you do is push P around the outside
paddle and the inside follows and cleans
the inside automatically no matter no
more struggling to clean the inside the
windshield wow applies firm cleaning
pressure for you and is super thin to
get into those tight Dash areas as well
so what are you waiting for go to
windshield wow.com use code Walsh a
check out for a special discount that's
windshield wow.com using Cod Walsh so if
I were to compile a ranking of like the
top 500 things I've ever been distressed
about in my life climate change wouldn't
make the list it wouldn't even make it
down near the bottom with the most
obscure things I've briefly worried
about in the past like brain eating
amibas and leprosy it's just not
something that makes it onto my
psychological Carousel of stuff to worry
about that's why I find it hard to
Fathom those people who are legitimately
afflicted by this so-called climate
anxiety but in the end I do believe that
such people exist because the constant
apocalyptic hysteria from the media is
is is designed to have this effect on
people and inevitably it will have this
effect on some people so if you are one
of those people who's uh dealing with
climate anxiety I have two things to say
to you here is some Eco anxiety
counseling that might actually help you
and I am trying to help you I'm not
being flippant I really am so the first
thing to realize is that you don't need
to worry about climate change not
because the climate isn't changing but
because climates always change it's what
they do I assure you it's how they
designed nature is in a constant state
of flux changing all the time there's no
reason to worry about this fact it gets
hotter it gets colder it rains it's
sunny this is the way the climate works
you probably don't have to worry about a
climate apocalypse that's not to say
that there will never be a climate
Apocalypse of A Sort I mean there will
be eventually the Earth will become
unhabitable look to our neighbor Venus
in the solar system and you'll get an
idea of what the Earth will be like one
day average temperatures of 800° fahit
clouds of sulfuric acid covering the
planet unbreathable toxic air just
absolute hell that will be the Earth's
fate but probably not for another two or
three billion years and and you probably
won't be around when that happens now in
the meantime you have more pressing
concerns there are thousands of other
things more likely to kill you and one
of them eventually will kill you you'll
probably get terminal cancer one day or
die of a heart attack or in a car
accident who knows maybe you'll be
murdered tomorrow something terrible
will happen to you eventually and it
will have nothing to do with climate
change I'm not sure this will make you
any less anxious but at least it should
make you anxious about more reasonable
things that's all I'm saying second
Point even if a climate apocalypse was
on the immediate Horizon even if we
really were barreling towards an
Armageddon caused by our SUVs and air
conditioning units um there wouldn't be
anything we could do about it at this
point and especially if that involves
turning off our air air conditionings
then we're definit I mean
if if you tell me that the way to save
the world is to turn off my air
conditioning and not use air
conditioning in the summer then I guess
the world's just going to end because
I'm not I'm not we're not doing that so
we're screwed anyway is what I'm saying
um by that logic we're living on
borrowed time simply waiting for mother
nature to exact her Vengeance and if
that's the case then why worry forget
the plastic storag M just live your life
until the ice caps melt and you're
washed away into the sea there's nothing
you can do to stop it your fate is
already sealed that may not be a
comforting thought but it is what it is
no point in wasting time wallowing in
anxiety over it now fortunately this is
not the case you will not drown because
of climate change you might still drown
I mean you could die that way maybe
you'll slip and hit your head and fall
into a hotel pool or something um but it
won't be because of climate won't be
because of climate change and either way
there's nothing to worry about you'll
die from something else sooner rather
than later you are under a death
sentence in 50 or 60 years you'll
probably be dead in a 100 years there
won't be anyone left even visit your
grave as you are decomposing in the
ground so cheer up is what I'm saying
and also I'm saying that climate anxiety
is today
cancelled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there